Welcome back everyone
its Charlie
This will be my Full Boys
Gen V Episode 6 Video.
There were a whole bunch Easter Eggs
and references.
Jensen Ackles Soldier Boy,
finally came back.
He was hilarious in this episode,
even though it was like mindspace,
Soldier boy.
The real soldier boy is still alive.
So don't worry, I'll explain that.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
And careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet.
just starting at the beginning,
working our way through shot by shot,
talking about Easter Eggs and WTF moments.
the episode title was Jumanji, a reference
to Kate sucking everyone into her mind,
kind of like the Jumanji movie
where everybody gets sucked into the game
in the hole.
Twist where if you die inside the game,
you die in real life.
If you die inside her mind
or you get trapped inside her mind
when it's collapsing and she turns into
a vegetable, as Soulja Boy tells them,
you won't.
That becoming a vegetable
also in real life
it's also a bit of a callback
to the earlier episode where she trapped
the dude in the loop, where he just kept
repeating the word Jumanji
screaming as he pounded his own nuts
if they were actually making another
Jumanji movie, maybe they would have
Soulja Boy do like some funny promo.
There were a couple of funny Soulja Boy
promos that they did for the episode.
like they did that
when they introduced the Soulja Boy
character, Jensen Ackles
character during the Boys Season three
that they just had him do those funny
Captain America style promos.
the actual opening scene is Kate
giving back everyone
their memories that she made them forget
basically the events of the past few days.
So everybody remembers
discovering the truth about the dean.
What is doing in the woods?
Remembering golden boy, Brother
Sam Pretty much everything.
Naturally. Everybody hates her
because she betrayed them.
And even worse, she'd been doing this
to Golden Boy for a way longer.
Like they realized the truth
that, like, Wait a minute,
how many times has she done this to him?
Sometimes she would make him forget
that he had a brother at all.
Sometimes
she'd make him think his brother was dead
because he keep remembering
and trying to save him
so she'd have to wipe his mind
over and over again.
she's kind of like the boys
universe version of Emma Frost,
because most of these characters in
The Boys are parodies of X-Men
Marvel characters, like on the boys
main series.
Most of them are parodies of Justice
League characters are like Marvel Avengers
characters pretty much everybody
on the spinoff or X-Men parodies.
the reason
why I say she's more of a parody of Emma
Frost than, say, like Jean Gray,
who also has psychic powers, is because
Emma Frost is just way, way darker.
She's way darker on the show
and she wore white clothing and gloves
like she wears on the show.
they're couple differences
in the way their powers work, like Jean
Gray, Emma Frost and Kate on the show.
They don't need a touch
you in the X-Men comics.
in the boys universe,
they're saying that there's some twist
behind wearing the gloves,
like somehow the gloves block her powers.
But here's the thing.
When she becomes
conscious briefly for a second,
they're not touching her,
but she still sucks them into her mind.
So she didn't need to actually
make physical contact
with all of them in order to do that.
this might be one of those situations
where she just believed a lie
that someone told her a long time
ago, like, if you put these gloves on,
it will stop your powers from working
when really that wasn't the case.
Like someone just told her that lie
when she was younger
so that she would believe it
and she wouldn't consciously
try to use her powers
when her gloves were on.
they kind of suggest this idea
during the episode, like maybe
she's way more powerful than we thought
she was, which is probably true.
they're kind of teasing that
with the Sam character, too.
Like there's all these new wrinkles
and aspects to his power that seem like
they're way more complicated
than just having Hulk like super strength,
is their dawn of the seven posters
all over the room, like a lot of seven
paraphernalia all over the place,
posters of the characters
like Starlight sit in her slutty
or more revealing costume.
The girls Get It done poster,
which is a big joke on the whole
A4 scene from Avengers Endgame,
the other
very timely, very funny thing about that.
Maybe it's a coincidence, but they're
actually doing the Marvel's movie now.
Like Captain Marvel too, in that movie
seems like it's based on the whole concept
of that a force scene.
Like they keep putting that A4 scene
in all the Marvel's trailers.
Kate kind of explains
why she was doing this,
then why she's passing out mid-sentence
like she thought
that she was doing the right thing.
But she was believing all the lies
the Dean and Brink were telling her, but
she ate it all up.
the Scooby Gang kind of learns the truth
through all of her memories in the past.
Like, she was being gaslit by the dean.
Like, the dean was just lying to her
this whole time and she believed it.
basically bring in the dean
lied to her, saying that they needed her
to do this to help golden boy
get stronger.
there was this weird aspect
that they were using,
that they were
taking something out of Sam, like
giving him transfusions of Sam's blood in.
Somehow that was acting like a performance
enhancing agent,
making his powers even stronger.
this is kind of like a subplot that they
don't completely explain in this episode.
Maybe they'll export in the final
two episodes where there's some aspect
to Sam's power that goes way beyond
just having super strength.
Cardoza was also using Sam
to develop this anti superhero serum.
But I think the idea is that Kate
also believe Vought might do something
terrible to Golden Boy.
All the other kids or something terrible
might happen to them if she did not do
what Brink in the dean
told her to do, wiping their minds.
normally
if superheroes get too out of control
or Vought doesn't
want to deal with the enemy anymore,
they'll either have them killed
or they're too powerful to be killed.
They'll put them in cryo storage
like they did with Soldier Boy.
like Ashley.
Spin machine at Vought
can only spin so hard.
Like, eventually
it becomes too much of a public problem.
They'll just put you in cryo deep storage.
We also learn
what's really going on with the dean.
Like her master plan.
The reason she tells Dr.
Cardoso not to inform Vought
after his success,
he finishes the v*rus to control
compound vs superheroes and tells him
to make it fatal, making it way stronger,
making it contagious.
pretty clearly implying
the Dean has her own side plot to kill
all compound vs superheroes,
and she's trying to weaponize the v*rus
and unleash it before Vought finds out
and can stop her.
remember earlier on the show,
the dean told Marie
she used to have a daughter
and she was kind of sad
about like I used to have a daughter.
She might have been killed by a superhero
and some kind of collateral damage
kind of incident.
Like Mother's Milk's family died
when he was younger
because Soulja Boy threw a car
through their house.
The Dean probably just swore revenge
when it happened to her
daughter and pretended to play along
with God's plan for the university.
The woods manipulated them in order
to weaponize this v*rus and kill all supes
They paint around the room like this
big American flag
is another Homelander reference.
We'll probably see him in the final
two episodes.
Like one of the final two episodes.
There's also a black noir sign, the wall
behind them, basically just paraphernalia
of all the seven characters
all over the school, all over the place.
Andre wonders
what was really going on with Kate.
How much did she know,
how long she'd been doing this?
The Golden Boy Did she force Golden Boy
to kill Brink, then himself?
Marie is probably correct, though,
in saying that
she had nothing to do with that. Like,
no, that was completely separate.
Golden boy. Just kept remembering.
Eventually, he remembered when,
after Brink accidentally killed him
and then just chose to kill himself.
the whole idea.
The episode here, like I'm
spending all this time in her mind
was the show wanting you to sympathize
with Kate more?
like look at her trauma,
Look at her damage.
This is why she did all these things.
It wasn't
because she was trying to be evil,
summary is correct in
guessing that Kate had nothing to do
with what's true plans with the words
creating the v*rus.
She didn't know anything
about what the dean was doing
or what Brink was doing.
Either just believed their lies
when they said that they were doing this
to make golden Boy stronger.
we just want to make him a better
superhero.
Like he'll be so much better after this.
Just wipe his mind ten, 15, 20 more times.
Just keep going.
yet imagine a couple of times
those you probably like.
How come they're screaming so much like
this doesn't seem like it's very humane.
Like, does he really need these?
do we really need to crack open his
brother's spine all these different times?
the funny moment here, though, like in
all this, is Andre is all traumatized.
He says he's made peace with everything
he learned about his father, polarity
being in on everything with remember
his father's meant to be like a magneto
reference to X-Men comics.
he's also a bit of a magneto
reference himself
because of their powers of magnetism.
You could also call his father a parody
of Polaris because of the name Polarity.
But he doesn't care
about learning the truth of his father.
And what's going on with Vought.
He doesn't care about the school
being a front for Vought.
Experimenting on people
like that doesn't bother him.
But the one thing he can't get past
was Kate's betrayal To be fair, though,
he does come around on her
at the end of the episode like he admits
he's still in love with her
and she seems like she's back on the team.
Like everybody's like, okay, fine,
we made peace with it.
You're cool now let's go after the dean.
But then Kate goes unconscious
because of a side effect of her powers.
If she uses them
too many times or for too long, or tries
to effect too many minds at the same time,
it will cause her brain
to basically melt down.
that's the way
they balance everyone's powers on the show
and keep them from getting to Opie,
because Homelander is still meant to be
like the most powerful person on the show
by far.
that's why Victoria Newman,
who can pop people's heads, cannot pop
Homelander's head.
like, as powerful as she is,
she still can't stop him.
I think they're saving that
for the Ryan character.
Like he'll be the person who potentially
become powerful enough to stop Homelander.
But I also think there'll be a big twist
there too.
Like it won't be as simple
as just Superboy versus Superman in
whatever the final season of the boys
winds up being.
Marie uses her blood bending powers again
to try and resuscitate, keeping her heart
and her brain working.
We learned that cardio is also finishing
the v*rus on Betsy, who
we saw earlier on the show.
She's the fire based superhero.
It looks like she just has a really,
really bad case
of the flu in that current form
of the anti superhero serum.
The other interesting thing here
too, is easy.
Seems like your typical
misguided scientist who's like, okay,
we have created a humane way
to control superheroes.
Very nonlethal.
But obviously the dean has their own
plans, like,
okay, why don't you make it stronger
and also weaponize it at the same time?
how many superheroes can we kill?
Like, clearly, the doctor
is probably picking up on this, like why
we need to make it contagious
unless we want to weaponize it.
We'll see how far things get before
the doctor starts working with the kids.
Or the kids wind up killing the doctor
When Kate sits up really quick,
then disappears.
Really cool effect of that.
They pull off,
I think the practical effect of them
getting pulled into her mind.
What's happening here
is that Marie's temporary fix worked.
Kate became conscious briefly
for like a hot second.
And in that hot second,
she lost control of her powers
and lashed out and just pulled them
all into her mindspace
in inside her mind, she's so powerful.
She's kind of like God, basically.
And that's
why the other kids powers don't work.
but this is why they're physical bodies
in the normal world are just lying there
unconscious around the house it's also why
everything in the background,
like the doors disappear
in that really cool way in while they're
witnessing all these memories of Kate's
in their own memories.
You see the background slowly
start to break apart.
there was a similar type of effect
in the darkness layer in the Upside-Down
during Stranger Things
season four where like you see things
floating around breaking apart in midair.
in obviously was the reason
why her mind is represented by the woods.
Here is the show
just revealing that she was so traumatized
by what she did to her brother
that she's always been thinking about that
since the moment that it happened.
Like her mind subconsciously in
sometimes consciously
has always been thinking about that day
in the woods.
She's always going back there mentally
in all the other aspects of her mind.
Just walk around in it
like the mind space version
of Soldier Boy, which was hilarious.
The reason
why he didn't know anything about Vought,
blaming him for the events of season
three and lying to cover it up
by saying that he was a sleeper
Russian agent was because he was a figment
of Kate's imagination, and Kate
didn't know that much about what happened
But this soldier boy was basically
a figment of Kate's imagination
She conjured up when she hit puberty
and wanted to learn about the big O, so
to speak, hunt the crap out of that pillow
on the regular.
the even funnier thing about this, too,
is that it wasn't homelander
that she thought of. Like she created
this. Her fictional boyfriend.
She chose Soldier Boy instead.
Like she liked him more.
Homelander in real life
would hate that if you learn like,
how dare you pick him instead of me?
in in reality, Soldier Boys
King is for older women.
So if the real actual soldier boy
learned that she was really into him
this way, he wouldn't really be into her
in the same way.
how ironic
he seems like he's
totally cool with Andre,
but also makes fun of him
for being her new boyfriend.
Like she always comes back to the pillow,
The reason why he knows about Andre.
Like, you're the new boyfriend
is because he knows everything
that Kate knows, because
he's a figment of her imagination,
like a representation of her imagination,
He explains.
The lightning is actually Kate's
blood vessels in her brain bursting.
So she's about to die,
taking them all with her as they all
revisit their own traumatic memories
that have kind of bled together
with Kate's traumatic memories.
this was a little bit like a therapy
episode inside her mind space.
Doctor, Soldier Boy is here to lead
you on the tour through the mind space
and all your traumatic memories.
we witnessed the events of Kate's brother
disappearing in them,
failing to find him.
That's how powerful she is.
She told her brother to leave
and never come back.
He was only six years old
and he never stopped obeying that command.
The idea is that he just hid
from the searchers and continues to hide
from them in present day.
So maybe like a big payoff for her
character arc at the end of the season
will be actually finding out
that her brother is still alive out there,
this is kind of Marie's thing, too.
Like she wants to find her
sister and reunite with her.
they just renewed the show for season two,
so they might actually save
some of that stuff for season two, though.
but then her mother
basically treats the young Kate
like a freak from then on, locking her
in her room using that hardcore vault door
for about the next nine years
until she goes to the university
to be fair to little Kate.
Her mother is the one who arranged her
getting the compound V dose
from Vought because she thought
that it would make their family rich.
in in the world of the boys.
That's basically
why all those kids parents
gave them compound V
treatments the children for money or fame.
they're a little ambiguous
about how Andre got his powers, though,
like they haven't completely explained
that if he got his powers at birth
biologically, like Ryan,
because his father polarity was a compound
B super, or if he got the compound
B treatments after he was born.
but because their powers are both
the same, like he's a magneto reference,
just like his father.
They have magnetism powers
then I think they're implying
that he was born with them in the comics.
It's a little bit different, though.
In the Boys comic book compound, V
is meant to make people sterile.
Like women can't get pregnant in.
Men can't conceive children either.
Homelander was meant to be like
the one exception to that in the boys
comic book, but they kind of
changed things for the TV show.
already talked about Jensen
Ackles, Soldier
Boy coming
back, loved all the scenes of him
just passing the hell out of all of them
in the stuff that he knows, some stuff
he doesn't know.
He also acts like he's kind of dumb
but also smart at the same time.
Like he knows all about the blood vessels
and gives us a very sciency explanation
for how her mind is breaking down,
But then at the same time, he's
kind of dumb in stumbles
through his attempts to make fun of them.
in real life, though, he's still in cryo
storage being held by Vought,
he can always come back
just and that goes like, yeah,
we could totally bring my character back
and it would be kind of twisty,
but we could do it
At the time when he was saying this out
to the boys season three,
I would think he was talking
a little bit about this.
Do you like the mindspace
version of Soldier Boy?
then R.I.P.
Mindspace, Soldier Boy, dies in her mind,
getting struck by that lightning,
which is actually a blood vessel bursting,
meaning that Kate, when she wakes
up, probably will just forget about him,
that he existed like,
yeah, maybe
I did use this mind space boyfriend,
but I don't quite remember
what was going on with that.
that's basically the end of this version.
Like if he comes back
it had to be like a completely different
version of Soldier Boy.
back in the real world.
Emma reunites with Sam.
They get it on in front of a polarity
clogging machine.
Andre's father
how appropriate to the episode
He sees the puppet version of her again
mid hump, but she's cool with it.
I think they just want to tease
their continuing relationship
and it's going to be kind of like a Hulk
in Black Widow kind of relationship
where she slowly talks him down every time
he seems like he's going to lose it
son's getting real low there.
But Then they see Kate's memory of the day
that the dean came to offer her
a spot in the university.
She's doing the homeschooling because they
literally won't let her leave her room.
Maybe there were a couple of times,
but for the most part,
over those nine years since the accident,
it seems that they kept her literally
locked inside that room.
she's got posters of all the seven
characters all over her room like Queen.
Maybe there's a poster
for a Crimson Countess movie
that she may call Whisky's Sunrise.
There's a poster of Soldier
Boy there, too,
for obvious reasons,
for a lot of pillow humping reasons.
Then the dean gives her a pill
that will suppress her powers,
enabling her to just operate
normally in real life.
that was probably one of his earlier
attempts at creating a chemical compound
to control superheroes,
like a lesser version
of what they're doing with the v*rus.
They jumped to her memory
of meeting Golden Boy at the university.
And because the memory of Golden Boy
knows everything that Kate knows
and their memory is also bleeding
indicates memories.
He knows everything that Andre knows
and becomes sort of this manifestation
of Andre's grief over what he did
getting with Kate
while she was still a golden boy,
basically cheating on him behind his back.
this is when they start seeing their own
traumatic memories bleeding in with hers.
the next one is like a previous time
where Golden Boy learned the truth
and came after Brink.
in his Jordan's memory helping subdue him.
trying to come to terms
with the idea that she believed
everything that Brink told her.
Like the reason why this is all going on,
even though subconsciously
she probably figured out
that it was all meant to be a lie
like this is all really us.
they visit Kate's memory of the woods,
seeing them experiment on Golden
Boy and Sam and Cardoza giving golden boy
the transfusion of Sam's blood.
Like I said, boosting his power
also probably something weird
going on with Sam's powers
that we don't fully understand yet.
Like some aspect to his powers.
They see her eating up.
The lies that bring in
the dean were telling her
about why she needed to wipe
everyone's memories.
then they visit Marie's traumatic memory
of the time she kills her parents.
She sees her sister again, reminding you
that that is something that she's
still trying to do,
like she's on a mission to find her sister
And Andre finally comes around on her,
admitting that he's still in love with her
and helping her wake up.
So basically, they're all cool.
But then Sam comes back
in, almost winds up killing her,
but it turns into like a Hulk black widow
situation where Emma talks him down.
Like I said, I think it does continue
to be a thing in the future,
going to be a little while before
he's right in the head.
There are only two episodes left.
So just based on the episode
seven trailer footage,
it seems like they're going after the Dean
and the doctor next.
Back in the Woods R.I.P.
Betsy,
because we learned that the dosage Cardoza
gave her,
even though was just like a tiny bit
more, was enough to kill her,
which the Dean thinks is amazing.
Like I said, because she probably wants
to weaponize it, killing all superheroes
so it sounds like the final two episodes,
are the Scooby Gang
stopping her before she can unleash that
on the rest of the world?
My other early theory
is that because we're getting cameos
in all these episodes,
we'll see a Homelander
cameo in either
episode seven or Episode eight.
They might save him
for the finale, though,
just because it's meant to directly lead
into the boys Season four,
like Homelander shows up
and just wrecks a whole bunch of people.
they also just renewed
Gen V for season two.
We don't know
when that's going to premiere,
probably 2025, just at the rate
they're going right now.
they called it
the show getting a sophomore year.
So the kids will come back
and be in university for sophomore year.
The play
get a new dean because early theory
they'll kill this of the dean
like the new dean that they get in season
two will be even worse.
kind of like an out of the frying pan
into the fire situation.
Like, you cleared one problem,
but another problem
that's way, way worse just crept up
There are a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references in the episode,
if you spotted any that
I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My episode 7 video will post next week.
After they release it, click here
for my full Loki Season 2 Episode 3
Video and click here for all my Boys
Gen V Episodes
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!